hi we're the cast of Outer Banks and
this is the wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
all right we're the cast of Sex in the
City you're watching Netflix
[Music]
I'll hold this for you oh let's Google
search does Madeline Klein ride horses
yes I ride horses one of my very first
jobs was working in a barn and in turn I
got to take care of horses so tell me
what's not to love a real horse girl
Dream Horse girl
who does Madeline Klein it depends on
how you read that see who does Madeline
play and knives out too I play whiskey
what does it like meeting your co-stars
anxiety-inducing
very exciting how old was Madeline Klein
in OBX I've booked it when I was 21 and
I'm 25 now so we've been at it for
almost four years wow wow is Madeline
Klein French
it might be because Val
maybe yeah and Outer Banks I've said
like we it's as French as it gets yeah
um
Chuck E cheese
[Laughter]
is literally a child Casino run by a rat
for children an adult rat I'm gonna ask
you about this later oh are we googling
me yeah
perfect is carlacia Grant coming back
from where
I never left so re-watch episode 10
season two and that answers that
carlacia Grant zodiac sign I mean you
can kind of guess and I'm a Capricorn
me and Michelle Obama have the same wall
just so many great people you know
hard-working driven nice the same
birthday a great friend does carlacia
Grant I feel like Wheel of Fortune lady
okay
it's coming out I said one karate class
when I was younger I don't know probably
nine and now I'm a black belt
I see a grant shows so I've been on the
very short-lived game of Silence on NBC
I've been on Greenleaf I was on the
Remake in Roots I'm on this very small
show called outer banks and
never heard of it good luck with it what
did carlacia Grant do what did you do
what did you do did you do oh my past
jobs maybe or like what did you do today
yeah I woke up I got cranked
I went back to bed got up again I did
some Glam anybody trying to understand
number one most commented thing on this
video is going to be what is cranky
perfect watch out for people's heads
I will be yours
can Madison Bailey play piano sort of
there's like I know like one song and I
can kind of play along a little bit if
I'm singing Stay by Rihanna actually I
was gonna say Itsy Bitsy Spider
who did Madison Bailey play in Black
Lightning I played Wendy Hernandez I had
wind powers
no looks a lot cooler in the show than
it does in my audition
Madison Bailey ukulele I play a little
ukulele in the show Just a Touch I've
definitely continued playing on as as an
adult I'm I'm learning a song now it's
Tim of No Woman No Cry the Black Panther
version it sounds beautiful on a ukulele
and I just got my nails off so I'm back
where is Madison Bailey from North
kakalaki I'm from Kernersville
population 12. you know myself
what is Madison Bailey's tattoo mean
which one I actually have four this one
right here is an 11 11. a non-personal
first matching tattoo with my girlfriend
actually I have love yours it's a J Cole
song it's basically reminding you to
love your life and there's no such thing
as a life that's better than yours he's
also from North Carolina so you know a
little little representation I have
lavender behind my ear for my mom and
then I have Handle With Care on my neck
because I'm sensitive
questions
I work here how did Chase Stokes start
acting I was doing television production
in high school as a way to get a better
GPA I kind of fell into it and then I
moved to LA in the rest is history
that's my directed TV production you did
yeah give me the Morning News yeah any
announcements everybody everybody ready
what does Chase Stokes eat everything
literally everything uh I am a human
dumpster yeah you put it in front of me
I will eat it was Chase Stokes drafted
to the USHL I was I was drafted by the
Waterloo Blackhawks the ush I was United
States hockey league so
um concussions and injuries yeah it just
seemed like a safer route which is
actually not really been the case I
think I've gotten hurt more in the last
four years on the show than I did my
entire hockey career it is
recently said in an interview that
nobody's seen me and Debbie in the same
room I think I'm gonna go with her
answer and please where did that start
Tammy yeah oh God yeah during covid I
put my hair into ponytails and created
an alter ego named Tammy it turned out
to look similar to Debbie Ryan and she
does that specific things people meme to
me and uh meme cultures great so I mean
to myself and now we're friends it's
great did Chase Stokes join the military
no I did not I just finished a film
about being in the military so that's
why I cut my hair it was a very
eye-opening experience and I'm very
thankful for those who serve and protect
your country now I took right
Jonathan Davis Google sure what is
Jonathan Davis this is his favorite
color right now it's like it's between
purple and blue I feel like it's just
more of like the vibe I see in my head
when I'm like doing things like you know
if I have to pick a color for something
I guess it's purpley I don't really
think about putting it on my body that
much I got a lot of black in my closet
so Jonathan Davis dog yeah yeah I got a
dog in me I got that dog
I have a real dog too his name's Titan
he's a German shepherd and foreign
it's funny him and Milo haven't met yet
but I'm just waiting for that
hyperactive meeting how did Jonathan
Davis
famous uh there's this show called outer
banks that came on Netflix not too long
ago for some reason everybody watched it
and decided it was good but it's like
for real there's something that changes
when you kind of like get around a group
of peers who are all kind of going for
the same thing you kind of like they rub
off on you honestly like all of you have
really inspired me to keep going and
have changed the way I've acted in a lot
of ways and a lot of the way I think
about the industry so thank you man
Jonathan Davis Conroe see how I said
Davis there like my accent came up
football yeah I did a couple years of
football from Conroe before I moved out
here full time and started acting
absolutely okay I was on Varsity so
varsity football is like college ball so
I was okay if I if I had like really
cared about the workouts or like had
been around to actually finish maybe it
had done something but I'm kind of glad
I didn't yeah but I do have a friend who
I play football with who is currently in
the NFL his name is Joseph assault he
plays for the Bengals went to the Super
Bowl good friend of mine I've known him
since the sixth grade last but not least
Jonathan Davis Tennessee Titans two
football questions recently I've made a
pretty good relationship with the
Tennessee Titans which is my favorite
football team I am from Houston they
used to be the Houston Oilers for
anybody asking why I'm a Houston Rockets
and Houston Astros fan and not a Houston
Texans fan it's because they used to be
the Oilers and now they're the Titans
I'm friends with the owner of the
Tennessee Titans now like I went to go
do like the 12th man for the Titan which
is like a thing where you like run out
onto the field and like put the sword in
the ground before the game it's like a
hype thing it was pretty beast and um I
met her on the field and then we started
talking football and they're fans of the
show and just made a good friendship so
got a lot of interesting friendships
like that like I never thought I'd be
friends with the owner of a football
team I gotta admit wow that was a good
one all right here we go three two one
what movie is really popular and Tom
Holland in together we were in a movie
called Uncharted and uh and a pretty
sweet guy how British is he in person
he's very British where was riponka born
I was born in Ketchikan Alaska
it was a fun isolating experience
emphasis on the ice riponko
candle candle do you have a candle set
he's starting a Candle Company what did
it smell like though I'm gonna google
this when I get home for real I want no
up the candle what I found was that you
showered with the candle I mean I feel
like we have how can we all like a
candle in the bathroom wait he knows
more about you than you know about your
shower I lived with you for a long time
right hey dude we got to go to work he's
like one second I'm showering with my
kids
like it keeps going out it is Rudy ponco
I'm going to be in Marvel I you know
what we have no idea Rudy ponco
no thanks
what is Outer Banks theme song
we don't really have a theme song I
think that's just what everybody knows
yeah that's the most popular song on
Tick Tock how does Outer Banks season
two ends
watch it oh
stop
and stuff go watch the show is Outer
Banks based on Romeo and Juliet I think
it's just a story as old as time to work
so yeah no it's not but I think it's
we're friends
let's do it okay what is the outer banks
handshake clap yeah
it's awesome simple can I watch Outer
Banks with my parents my parents might
be a little mature for parents it's fine
yes did you watch with your parents
everyone yeah family show why watch
Outer Banks why not correct you got our
questions
well thank you guys for watching our
wired autocomplete interview hope you
enjoy it and season two on Netflix
[Music]